wait yo what's up guys is prestige Nick
interrupted me what's up this prestige
and I'm going to be this is whoa look at
look how sexy look miss Alma I'm going
this is a new server server survival
thingamabob we're going to do and we're
started off with an explosion new car
and yeah it's called feed the beast and
it's basically if you ever heard of
Tekkit it's like that- some stuff plus
some other stuff now this is our old
house it is a piece of crap is that it
is a turd and you can see cuz i
discovered that with the thing called a
minimum stone you can make stuff
different so i just had a head head
today doing that and ya know pink
addressed oh that's a good idea next
take a chest so we we did that made this
house just to learn everything how to do
stuff and yeah all that so we're
bringing all our machines and nick my
bro Nick made this giant super power
source that's like infinite energy that
like teleports lava and stuff it's
complicated I don't understand it
melissa nick you didn't take the iron
chest you take it okay so yeah we are
gonna blow everything up with two nukes
no for nukes to you made these hardcore
legit due to jet irials but we are going
to teleport away we're not gonna
teleport away as when the news go off
we're gonna teleport away after bloke
the nukes to the new house or a new area
for house so cal plays a nukes 12 we
should really have a big adoro to get
out uno dos okay I agree okay break the
walls Nick the course will take care for
years okay and um yeah that thing is
Nick play some blocks that can't be
broken so good job Nick alright uh run
raid ok so we should be pretty safe from
the explosion I just don't want to get
safe at all I just don't want to get hit
with radiation that's what not
oh and if you see so yeah basically it's
like a ton of mods and if you see this
weirdo biome all gosh get radiation X
know if my server closes it's not my
fault man and this is just some cracks
and so yeah it's all mine we should have
went in there for shelter not sure well
I already got radiation so I'm going
back why do I feel like our house is
still there because I can still see it
oh it's gone it is gone Yes Mother yeah
there's gonna be gonna be an intro
episode i'm gonna show some stuff and
yeah and Willie my breath oh my gosh
holy but so yeah that Owens I was sorry
so sorry let me turn my render distance
up a little bit sharp let's get some
normal guys don't a guitar intro uh huh
okay well if any of you have been
hardcore super long term subscribers um
and that's like three of you because
when I say that I just mean from my
previous channel Nick appeared on that
channel you want to say hello hello so
yeah most of you are new even people
that have been around for a really long
time this channel so yeah I play Hunger
Games Nick so we blew this stuff up and
I'm going to take out that way point
since yeah this deletes good idea eat
okay now I'm gonna have Nick teleport to
the new Waypoint nectary palpitation new
house I said say new land and now nick
is gonna teleport me there oh my gosh
this is such an awesome exposed yeah one
nuke she didn't really do much but like
if you had two nukes or four nukes it
like does like exponentially larger
amounts of damage tific rounds yeah it's
cool hey my radiations gone oh by the
way this is called nanos your armor Nick
made it when I wasn't playing and he
made one for him and one for me and it's
like with carbon which is made from like
their decomposed coal this is really
complicates it's gonna take a long time
to understand everything so I don't
leave it Nick understands may also make
understands half of it I don't
understand half of what Nick understands
doesn't has played it more than me any
I'm too bright are you gonna teleport me
I got you back / GP med Luigi drop down
the home on Nick you didn't do it oh I
basically can't gain falling damage so
you see half art this is all peaceful to
off peaceful i know i'm gonna yell I'm
peaceful what do I make a backpack and
when all you did stuff from your chest
is here it said the player cannot be
found man you're lost forever how about
I just do this listen bees next save me
here you're up just TP to me TP add
Luigi what do i do mad Luigi then demon
wolf no yes I don't know I don't know
even if it doesn't work I do not have
permission I just hope ed with the D ok
thanks / TP you didn't give me the
message that I gotta pee yeah you see we
are we are not that good at this demon
wolf oh there we go oh I'm too good
thank you thank you and by the way these
things are the most terrible pieces of
poop every excellent should be up man I
never got off but okay and an egg made a
bunch of chest oh my gosh why is there a
lava wall over there d3m and the knee oh
my gosh oh oh my gosh what take this
force is amazing guys yeah they have
austin for sad and like new biomes stuff
look at what that looks like in the
minimum that's great okay I'm let's like
make a house
niklas is like a house all right I would
love to make a house all right so yeah I
guess you missed it oh my gosh so I can
get my awesome tech yeah so we we done
some survive with some hardcore doing
all thanks for the colony you're welcome
appreciated all right up I have rubber
wood I mean y'all wouldn't even know
what normal what is overrated all right
there's easy there there bunch of portal
inspire parts to this mod this mod K so
oh my god why did you place the
different ones why I think if I did
nothing not a different ones they're
normal these are the normal ones you I
just heard him say yeah I know but
they're the normal ones are so basically
these are the most annoying thing in the
entire game that one's name is Carolyn
not even hairline caroline is too
mainstream okay now I'm gonna run
through okay take it off peaceful okay
they died when you walk through or
already just going through what no
kiddin know our this first episodes
gonna be a peaceful guys okay that'll
work the bill I did put down the I'm
different ones like I heard it too I
just didn't think it was alright um we
need to make house I have twilight
oakwood i know i just gave it to you I
hope you like wood planks oh we have
known planks okay I'm where you want
make the house I I don't know right over
there I'm just getting the wood oh this
is a pretty awesome place good job Nick
thank you thank you i try so yeah we're
gonna make a house that would make
awesome factories you guys got to tell
us what types of factory we should make
I heard one guy like he's like I'm gonna
make an MMO fact but that's too that's
too main ship what he saw mainstream
can't do that um I think over here is a
good place for house
Oh make I found a good place for a house
this is this kind of this kind of
reminds me of the where I lived for the
urban survival like this this hill it's
late here oh it's late hey Nick doesn't
live in the tents n times on his being
where do you want to put the house no
mother yeah I haven't seen any new mobs
those that's an appt stupid Chris you
see these crystals are terrible I'm
saying new mobs oh so that's the thing
nothing the one house hey sometime well
okay well okay hey I explain now so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make a
little porter that travels us to the
twilight zone and in the twilight zone
there are many listen oh yeah there are
new stuff in the twilight zone Bors dang
this is a good place for a house here i
was thinking under the overhang so we
don't get the annoying rain sound okay
why are you destroying flowers with an
axe cuz i need the portal do you need
those flowers for the portal ya know you
do okay that what we needed did you have
any torches audience pliers hardly make
a portal should we live in the pool
should we live in the twilight zone no
okay given to over would you know I have
it I'm sure pretty sure has all the
exact same properties whoa a basalt
cobblestone volcano you kidding what a
little boys there's a volcano over here
see you Nick did you should ask your
viewers if they want snacks if you they
want you to have slacks oh no like what
do you use if you guys know what facts
isn't sure well if you want to watch
come here calm this down I'm getting
something in some fireflies 5 Liza's but
I'm here I'm getting some fireflies a
place by our house I will kill you this
is where our house is gonna be come look
at this
give the overhang I was there he's in
fireflies okay okay go die I was getting
fireflies for light I don't need you Oh
guys you should comment on Nick's high
voice oh your own bastard haha uh I
reply oh gosh that's better that's much
better I fly so yeah you can see that
they basically act as torches cuz I
didn't think I added many torches Matt
do you have bleeping out software or my
free I'm not agree on the mic I'm not
gonna believe since it takes too much
energy yeah freedom of speech ok where
do you want to put the house in here
speech me where do I put the house I
want to put the house in this thingy
what's up in addition
whoo want to say where you want the
house no you're still thinking Matt that
pumpkins eyeballing me I'm scared
they're cool Nick we should make the
house in this like section of space in
between the chunks of land neck neck
neck yes let's make it up there is any
way to zoom like like zoom no no I don't
have any see the base cuz they're news
okay yeah we should make it like in
between these two thing is I got my rib
this mask on someone's gotta get that's
nice do you have any of three shovels
some peaceful at I've Nanosuit armor
yeah so it's not like you can take
damage with nano sudama you got some
sheep eyeballing us from above ribbons
mask oh did you did you get some shovels
or we could live at the top of that
volcano or we could not live on the top
of the volcano cuz then be [ __ ] we
should live on the top I want to live on
top of volcano you have enough Kabul man
I will kill you no we're not living
there cuz we can't build anything under
it your Bersani yeah we can it wait is
it all love under it I look you write it
all love under it yes are you sure no I
just lied to your face ok I want to live
it it you're respected why mentally
handicapped what hey everybody comment
about how he is mentally handicapped my
viewers love me beauty nurses they just
watch you because of how much they hate
you example I love your logic inc thank
you oh it's hard
we should live on nothing Nick we're not
leaving us why is your crafting broken
no my thing is just broke another mind I
lied i'm taking a bond I'm gonna go
check out if it's love under it dang I
sure won't take a bucket of water no
matter if it's love bird oh no matter if
it's love or not we're not living there
why it's such an awesome like precipice
there's a bucket of water you should go
like it's like an awesome place is just
like like a yo look at this perfectly
open beautiful spot to place like you're
out the space under the overhang I'm
gonna investigate oh look at that show
home at that show I'm very far away from
you dat shovel I'm investigating yeah
sorry if this is not the most activity
in episode oh this is pretty riveting um
there we go there's some blockage yeah
yeah yeah so we're gonna live wait I'm
gonna go black that waterfall so hard
it's not even gonna know what hit it
Nick I think there's only um I think
there's one strain of it I'm going all
the way like like Oh single one by one
more no on the volcano right living I'm
the volcano therefore making our
basement in the volcano but there's only
one like a thing of lava no one spout
I'm making outpost to your neck okay you
can have your outpost there that's not
where houses be gonna be her post what
sweet what should we put here Matt do
you wanna stab lollygaggin come help me
clear out the land I'm making now post
that is very vital to survival make the
statue of me filling a small turtle
again ah it was it was a baby uh he
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] [ __ ] Boyardee
smiting a turtle I've made that post
Nick it she'll serve as an altar later
on yes you how do you want to come like
yeah help me clear how long you live in
recording i have no idea i never know
how long I've been recording because I'm
always full screen in the Minecraft hard
how long are your episode is gonna be
like 15 minutes 15 to 20 what are you
doing what the what are you doing I'm
clearing what to know up and Nick Nick
come back reckon it no no no we're not
living up on that piece of living up ya
know why why would we live up there then
the rain would still get us Oh chill I
don't care leave our house right here in
this corner in
okay then why are you destroying that
other stuff destroyed it I want a big
enough I'm making a big enough man Conda
what are you making big enough don't
understand your logic pic you don't need
to understand it it's just a logic Ruby
here been a burden huh what Rams are
sloths cloth wrong go ahead yet one two
three four five six seven foot one two
three four five Sonny even think I see
you wanted all the answer to my riddle
oh ooh bad I don't want to tell you the
answer okay that's good I like a date
Nick I make an eight ya know you better
make the house not look like sloppy
garbage I'm making one wall to walls at
the moment sloppy garbage walls
options truck video settings I mean
they're fart yeah I need another Firefly
one sec there's my light where's your
dick these I'm changing you back to
default texture pack okay you check long
I've been recording how do i check that
I have no idea oh thank you thank you
man I can eat some more wood will go
into your chest then how much is so far
away yeah now I'm just gonna check um
I've been recording for I have no idea
how long it's lovely thank you Miss
everything looks so bad on default oh my
god oh my god oh you guys want me to if
you guys want me to get a texture pack
and a name it for me and I might do it
I'll give you this Nick come to my house
and I'll show you what I'm thinking of
come to your house well until you put
something in it it does not our house
bring someone with you how would I place
an egg in it yeah here so and and and
right there I make a doorway there and a
door where there's multiple doorways I
know not all right there what the think
I might have done this wrong what is
that slappy piece of small garbage it's
the freakin house clear what
we're going to live in the factories end
up this will be the base house and we'll
have factories branching off from the
easiest please okay mmm I have a diver
Tom shovel nice i just gave it to you
you mean I just teleported it to me
myself with my magic numbers yeah you're
happy indeed hopefully my viewers like
you since they seem to vary like me I
and they're saying I have no idea why
you guys like me just saying tell my
viewers like I've I told many people
this when I've been doing YouTube like
you guys seem to really like love like
the heroine series and that stuff and to
tell you the truth I have no idea why
they love your voice okay so hopefully
you'll also love Nick's voice it'll be
the foil to my voice oh I could listen
to bein talk hey in person this is a
terrible pain depression just joshing
jamming I just pushed my mic into my
mouth whoa mr. UPS man doll UPS bond you
even hit you there you um Nikki kind of
hacking hard you're hanging stop hacking
why you is the dirt stop it are you
meant in the head again out you ask I um
I guess is a good spot to end it since
we're production house and you saw the
explosion nothing how much a seven I
think we'll get the house built and then
we'll start recording the next episode
all right we'll help you have y'all
enjoyed this so much i love your faces
um yeah that one who said that total
buscus someone said i love your faces
anybody knows Alaska's is still doing
are literal anymore um ninety percent
sure he is good good good ok this one
out you look good at now that's nice
yeah boy sparks about a like it
everybody okay no that is terug I hate
him I do not endorse the channel at all
I kind of indoors Toby's channel know
everybody the Timothy guys screw all
right guys well I hope you have enjoyed
this video if you have gone if you or so
this is gone this is my mindset if you
guys make it all the way to the end of
one of my videos I feel like you have
really enjoyed it and if you really
enjoyed it then i feeI do hope that you
give it a like and if you're new to my
channel then I really appreciate a
subscribe and also say I'm intimidating
like it no don't if you want more videos
then basically I post a video up I wait
till it gets a good amount of views they
don't give another video so if you want
more videos then tell your friends about
it and get them to get more views and
share your friends about it had like 0
video shared in total so yeah um my
heart did you do your hunger not go down
peaceful no are you know well hope you
all enjoy it ok I hate my eyes so much
oh gosh my hair Bernard so much better
I'm hair man Herbert arc I'm attacking
you in at five mode oh gosh this is
difficult mention combat like this ah
yeah I think I'm attacking you yeah yeah
oh yeah okay enough of this enough of
this killin not for this is hurt you
enjoyed um yeah subscribe like and I'll
see y'all later deuces yeah you stop
breaking dirt it's quite loud I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay